so there's a new report out that while
shocking
shouldn't be hugely surprising to
anybody who's been paying attention for
the last six years
uh in a new book by wall street journal
reporter michael bender
bender writes that donald trump
told his then chief of staff john kelly
in 2018
that hitler yes adolf hitler
did a lot of good things now remember
that the wall street journal is owned by
news corporation that's the same company
that owns fox
news this is not some left-wing
publication or left-wing reporter
uh the story goes that this took place
during a visit to europe for the
hundredth anniversary of the end of
world war one now you might
i actually remember this was one of the
many disastrous trips that trump took
and i believe this was the one where he
ended up not going somewhere and they
claimed it was because of fog but he
just wanted to hang around and watch fox
news there was like some leaf ring
wreath laying ceremony something like
that i believe that's the same trip here
and during that trip donald trump
insisted to john kelly
who at the time was his chief of staff
that well hitler did a lot of good
things
the comments reportedly stunned john
kelly
this is all in a book that's hilariously
titled
frankly we did win this election uh you
know that's that's uh trump the guy
of course who who is saying that
congratulations sir you just won the
election
yeah um now the comment itself is
outrageous and stunning there are rumors
that trump
used to keep a copy of hitler's speeches
on his bedside table
trump doesn't read that's the one thing
that makes me doubt that but it's
certainly possible
but the context here is actually even
more interesting uh trump apparently
blurted this out
during the trip when john kelly started
explaining basic history to trump i
guess as was frequently done
before an event people around trump
would try to give him a little
information
about how the world works so that he
would maybe be able to avoid humiliating
himself
and in so doing john kelly reminded
trump
what were the different countries on
each side of world war one
and then kelly explained how world war
one connected to world war
ii and of course the holocaust and the
atrocities of adolf hitler and in that
context
trump's um contribution trump's
interjection was well hitler did a lot
of good things
it's an american president folks
reportedly saying this
now of course trump's new spokeswoman
liz harrington
says it's all made up she says quote
this is totally false
president trump never said this it has
made up fake news
probably by a general who was
incompetent
and was fired however bender
seems to have done his job and his
homework and has multiple sources on
this and in fact multiple people told
bender
everybody in the room was saying to
trump no no no no no
hitler didn't do great things and they
were clearly horrified that
trump might say that publicly at some
point and trump reportedly insisted
according to multiple sources no
hitler did do great things like for
example
leading the german economic recovery in
the 1930s now
even that shows trump's complete
ignorance and his deference
to authoritarian and in some cases
genocidal uh
leaders trump seems to have no idea that
the so-called german economic revival
was hugely based on wealth that they
stole from the people that they
eventually murdered
uh what i would have given to have been
a fly on the wall
during this conversation and bender adds
in the book that kelly told trump
even if your claim about the german
economy
under the nazis was true like even if it
were true
that hitler did great things
economically quote
you cannot ever say anything supportive
of adolf hitler you just can't
and kelly clearly realized that if he
didn't explain that to trump
next thing you know trump might be
praising hitler in public and the book
more
generally outlines how clueless trump
was
about every aspect of history quote
senior officials
described his understanding of slavery
jim crow
or the black experience in general
post-civil war
as vague to non-existent but trump's
indifference to black history
was similar to his disregard for the
history of
any race religion or creed
it's actually crazy but this sounds like
the type of things some trump supporters
would actually say in defending trump
like when you confront a trump supporter
and you say listen trump is really
authoritarian
his tendencies are like duterte
and they're like kim jong-un and they're
like putin and you know
some aspects are even hitlerian in some
way
okay man but hitler did some good things
i mean the economy did well and the
trains ran
on time or whatever it sounds exactly
like the prototypical trump supporter
and i don't typically read these types
of books i didn't read fire and fury i
didn't read you know all of these
different ones
uh frankly we did win this election
sounds like one i may actually want to
look at but certainly nothing
shock it's shocking but it's not a
surprise
if you've been following donald trump
for as long as anybody who's been
following american politics has been
doing it and
curious to see if trump will say
anything about it himself
one of our sponsors is four sigmatic the
company
best known for their delicious mushroom
coffee
four sigmatics mushroom coffee is
organic
fair trade single origin arabica coffee
with both lion's mane and chaga
mushrooms chaga mushrooms have actually
been shown to have potential in
supporting the immune system in
peer-reviewed studies
i've been drinking four sigmatic coffee
a lot lately it actually doesn't taste
anything like mushrooms it just tastes
like
any delicious coffee but it's really
easy on my stomach doesn't give me any
jittery feeling or a midday crash and
they have over
20 000 5-star reviews
and best of all if you don't love it
you'll get 100
of your money back because they stand
behind their product
you've got nothing to lose by giving it
a try four sigmatic is giving my
audience up to 40 percent off
and free shipping when you go to
4sigmatic.com
pacman the link is right underneath this
video